machine learning teach a computer how to
perform a task without explicitly
programming it to perform said task
instead feed data into an algorithm to
gradually improve outcomes with
experience similar to how organic life
learns the term was coined in 1959 by
arthur samuel at ibm who was developing
artificial intelligence that could play
checkers half a century later and
predictive models are embedded in many
of the products we use every day which
perform two fundamental jobs one is to
classify data like is there another car
on the road or does this patient have
cancer the other is to make predictions
about future outcomes like will the
stock go up or which youtube video do
you want to watch next the first step in
the process is to acquire and clean up
data lots and lots of data the better
the data represents the problem the
better the results garbage in garbage
out the data needs to have some kind of
signal to be valuable to the algorithm
for making predictions and data
scientists perform a job called feature
engineering to transform raw data into
features that better represent the
underlying problem the next step is to
separate the data into a training set
and testing set the training data is fed
into an algorithm to build a model then
the testing data is used to validate the
accuracy or error of the model the next
step is to choose an algorithm which
might be a simple statistical model like
linear or logistic regression or a
decision tree that assigns different
weights to features in the data or you
might get fancy with a convolutional
neural network which is an algorithm
that also assigns weights to features
but also takes the input data and
creates additional features
automatically and that's extremely
useful for data sets that contain things
like images or natural language where
manual feature engineering is virtually
impossible every one of these algorithms
learns to get better by comparing its
predictions to an error function if it's
a classification problem like is this
animal a cat or a dog the error function
might be accuracy if it's a regression
problem like how much will a loaf of
bread cost next year then it might be
mean absolute error python is the
language of choice among data scientists
but r and julia are also popular options
and there are many supporting frameworks
out there to make the process
approachable the end result of the
machine learning process is a model
which is just a file that takes some
input data in the same shape that it was
trained on then spits out a prediction
that tries to minimize the error that it
was optimized for it can then be
embedded on an actual device or deployed
to the cloud to build a real world
product this has been machine learning
in 100 seconds like and subscribe if you
want to see more short videos like this
and leave a comment if you want to see
more machine learning content on this
channel thanks for watching and i will
see you in the next one